I'd rather I'd rather the family to be
honest but overall a good man so I can't
get my hair done
I'm just doing makeup for do you make up
for yourselves you do live it for
yourself or do you do it to look
attractive to a man I mean some people
deserve to be tolerated some people
deserve to be liked but not everybody
deserves to be loved for 13 years you
can you can't really go out your friends
can only come to you you guys go down in
lifestyle for a family
so say
no Nails no hair very little makeup
budget but you get a man
for a lifetime loyal he's everything you
want but you have to go down in
lifestyle you maybe get what what's you
pick the amount they get a month for
recreational Auntie's better with the
budgeting recreational for them for the
whole household or just for them for
them I think they get to spend on
themselves everything else is the kids
or the family 500 pound a month 500
pounds a month
no man's perfect but he does everything
that I need him to do yeah but you live
in where do they live auntie I think
Auntie's gonna give the better picture
where do they live living kind and a
tablet
I mean I've come from a tower blog so I
don't really
yeah so you go from you go from say like
a house a big house in like Primrose
Hill
on your own
to go into a tower Block in Cannington
with your perfect man and your perfect
family
but in order to do that don't forget
your building with him
but in order to do that you're not
allowed to no Nails no makeup because
you can't afford it just yet how often
how often can they go out with the girls
[Laughter]
how come
it could be just like a dinner or like
whatever kind of food dinner you'd
invite the girls in for a night in oh a
night and how often can they do that
once a month once a month yeah so it's
either that or I'm just on my own base
or you go out with him yeah to be if I'm
being completely honest but he's your
perfect man perfect like you've got two
kids perfect I'll be comfortable like
it's not the kids are paid for it you're
the only thing you can't they can't
afford is your upkeep
I'd rather I'd rather the family to be
honest family yeah wait so I can't get
my hair done
I just would say what makeup nothing
nothing for how long is that like for as
long as it takes for you to get out of
the kids till the kids are let's see 10.
all right I'll say 15. I'll compromise
13. there's no like divorce inside like
this is my perfect match this is you
know I mean for young forever man you're
still gonna fight you know a bit you're
still you know human you'll fight you
know now and then but overall a good man
but yeah for 13 years you can you can't
really go out your friends can only come
to you that's really it
I mean I already have my perfect man so
I don't mind I don't necessarily need to
do all the hair nails makeup because
he's already there so I guess I would
take the family and the man yeah
yeah family all day how should you wear
makeup for do you make up for yourselves
you do a little bit for yourself or do
you do it so it's look attractive to men
no I don't do it to attract men or
anything I do it for myself because I do
love hair and makeup and I do love
getting my nails done it just I'm just
used to doing that
didn't you just say yeah
it's just because you wouldn't normally
would go into a club with no makeup on
in your bald head cane Rose no one's No
One's Gonna Do it when you go out yeah
you dress yourself up to attract your
opposite sex do you do it to feel good
too however you do it for the up for the
opposing person so if I've already got
my man if he accepts me with no wig no
makeup bashes no then I'm good to be
fair yeah exactly that's basically you
see me getting no makeup on my hair back
and stuff like that I've done it I've
done it and I've just done it because I
want to go out and listen to music I
don't care about being attractive to no
one because I don't care I just want to
drink and just to enjoy music so I've
done it but then again I don't wear
makeup
we'll get my nails done
I'll do you know what somebody needs to
give me a makeover I want one of them
bigger wigs I want to get eyelashes I
want to see how different I look I want
makeup I want to get the nails done what
do you think Pearl give me a on makeover
an auntie makeover yeah and yeah
anti-anti makeover Auntie makeover I
think we could do that when yeah when
Melanie King comes to town she could
Style Both of Us yeah something
yeah
do you think people do you think
everyone
um
this is another thing I got in trouble
for
they come for me for no reason really
honestly so do you think everyone
deserves love
no no
yeah you think everyone deserves love
yeah what about
Hitler
uh he's going and face the onion mother
could love
his own family would have that he would
have love for his own family that's it
but he doesn't deserve love from like
anyone else do you think yeah everyone
deserves love
I mean some people deserve to be
tolerated some people deserve to be
liked but not everybody deserves to be
loved okay so we think that they don't
do you think they had love in their life
though Hitler had someone Jeffrey had
somebody regardless
but they still had it but it's not
dessert they had it but they didn't
deserve it it could be sick love you
don't think love is earned
um life should be young depending on who
it comes from it should be unconditional
like her mother and child it should be
unconditional love you shouldn't have to
earn your parents love I think I think
that you're I think children deserve
love but I don't think adults deserve
love
why not I think everyone deserves to
know what love feels like unconditional
she means
adults don't you you could love somebody
but you may not like them but you know
what I mean and I think that's a
difference I think a love is an
extremely strong emotion that we kind of
underwrite because you can be in we've
done it I'm sure you know I've been in
uh relationships I shouldn't have loved
that person but I did because it's it's
an emotion that's created you know what
I'm saying it's not earned you create
love you said you can love someone but
not necessarily like them yeah I think
the other way around so you could like
somebody but not love them yeah I tend
to that's easy I tend to dislike anybody
but save the love for special people but
some people like certain family like
parents for example
um I love my dad because he's my dad but
I don't like him as a person you can
love someone
but not necessarily like the person that
they are now you just say I like him
because he's my dad's and that's what
society says no but I love him because
of certain there's certain memories and
stuff you have with that with particular
people about my parents I like my dad
because he's my dad
that's it
Nelson he's a bad dad but it's just that
I love my grandchildren
that's it love is a sick thing as well
like I think love is just so complex do
I mean because it's like let's stay away
from the family love because that's like
easy let's stick to the kind of romantic
love
I mean I I don't know why for some
reason I've just got like pimp and
in my head I don't know why but it's
like these men you know abuse these
women but they fall in love I don't know
it's so strange like like I said love is
it's sickening you can't sometimes you
can't work out you can't comprehend it
with the mind it is literally an energy
or an emotion so it's not infatuation or
something it could be
is that infatuation is that love
um
what's that is that Stockholm syndrome
yeah when you love your Capital yeah
just love comes in many shapes and forms
me like we'll all sit here as different
people that's the mental illness isn't
it stop from syndrome that's men or love
so okay it's love in the mind or is it
in the body women had to do that because
before what would they do they would
kill if one tribe overtook another tribe
they would kill the children and the men
and take the women so like women had to
Evolution it like if they wanted to pass
on their genes they had to fall in love
with their Captor also it's like a
coping mechanism essentially oh I don't
know
it's like arranged marriages also I
don't know if that's the same thing
it's about it's about lions and the Cubs
you know when when the tribes take over
and then you say arrange marriages all
kinds of because some of those people in
their cultures they don't have a choice
like whoever they're given to that's who
and it's still real to this day that's
that's not that's not what arranged
marriages are like what is it what is it
like they have a choice they get the
people and they actually have a choice
okay it's not like this is a person
you're gonna marry him they say this is
what we're looking for in a man that's
what we're looking for in a woman and
the families talk and eventually they
meet and if they don't like each other
they say I don't like them and then they
go and choose again I don't know I think
in some countries
um maybe not so much here but in some
countries I think that they don't have a
choice these young girls that are given
to these older men I don't think they
have a choice when the family sell them
for money and stuff
personally I think that definitely does
exist that's an exception but that's not
that's not what umbrella's marriages
actually are word that's abuse would you
guys consider yourself modern or
traditional
modern women are traditional women
[Music]
um
identify falling there's I still have a
lot of traditional
um values but I also
do have a lot of modern takes on things
so I don't I don't think I fall into
either bracket to be fair could you tell
me how are you modern how are you
traditional so like what Traditional
Values do you have and like what about
you is modern
um traditional in a sense of I feel like
um women should
take care of house and home and I feel
like men should be providers of a
household
um
however I do also feel like in this day
and age
I'm not I don't really like calling
people or or any or things
like that like if you want to whoever
you want to see but who you want to
sleep with like it doesn't so you're
more modern because you're not
judgmental yeah essentially okay but you
do believe in women taking care of the
home and men going to off to work
basically no definitely I feel like
women I feel like it's as women you
should know how to cook food you should
know how to clean a house you should
know how to just those basic things I
think that's forgotten a lot in this in
this day and age women don't know how to
cook food or just bait they'll know how
to drink and go out partying but don't
know how to season food or cream chicken
or anything like that I think that needs
that's not something that's as common
anymore um
for me I'd say I'm more traditional I
would only say a modern in the sense of
I don't like to judge people
but I'm definitely more traditional in
the sense of like you know
keeping yourself to marriage taking care
of the household the children letting
the man be the brain like um The
Breadwinner and things like that
um so yeah what traditional skills do
you have
um can you sell uh yeah I can actually
say you can sell yeah I learned how to
sew when I was a kid so what else I
clean the house I cook
um yeah just take care of the home
really like I'm always cleaning at home
so are you a virgin
no no not that one okay go ahead okay if
we're gonna go traditional okay go ahead
I think when it comes to matters of the
heart I'm more traditional
um what makes me a modern woman is the
fact that I'm you know pursuing a career
basically without relying on a guy
so you would
pick one
traditional you're a traditional woman
okay yeah team I'm a traditionalist
with modern gadgets
so yeah I'm not traditional I'm not
modern I'm this a traditionalist
attenter
like the traditional stuff
I tend to try and follow that way they
want to know in the chat what cultural
dishes
um because everyone said they could cook
what cultural dishes can you cook
um Frosty chicken rice Kali curry
chicken roti
dalid
Trinidadian okay what traditional or
what um cultural dishes can you cook
well I'm Congolese so I'll make rice and
pundu at home and for the Congolese
people they'll know okay what else what
else
um well a lot of Congolese is like
fondue Madison I'm not sure a lot of
people know about that unless you're
congrelease yourself
um yeah it's a love right this rice
dishes are also like a lot of pasta
dishes
um yeah but okay what about you um so my
Heritage is Jamaican and British
um but my ex-husband was Colombian so I
learned a lot how to infuse so anything
from scratch really whether that's a
fried English breakfast or a pasta meal
or a chicken stew or you know any of
anything from scratch there's love and
passion do you think traditional women
are virgins foreign
if you're going to use if you're going
to take the word as it is then yeah yeah
no I'm not I don't think so no no what
do you think Katie I've been the
traditional word for traditional women
is Virgin I think that traditional women
are virgins I'll tell you why because
traditional is putting the family before
yourself right and I think the most if
we're gonna like do the archetype of
like ideal traditional women they're
thinking about the family from the time
they're like 12 13 14 so they don't want
to have sex with anyone else because
other than their husband
because they don't want to bring that
into a marriage so if we're going to do
like the ideal archetype of like what is
the ideal traditional woman I I would
argue it's probably a virgin
I agree because they're they're thinking
Family First from like a very young age
they would never get divorced
um career really isn't first for that
like it's always family before career
everything's Family First
is there anything else you guys would
add to that that I missed
as far as being traditional yeah
I think like her attitude as well
towards her man um
yeah that's a good one then trying to
dominate or be in control even be equal
just that yeah it's about being able to
submit to your man your husband I think
it's sex on tap
I think that sits on tap when he wants
it as much as possible I think that's
what a lot of women will struggle with
what do you struggle with
can traditional women cheat ever no if
they're traditional then no no no
[Music]
yeah they're not gonna know about it
you think a traditional woman can cheat
yeah she can take care of the home and
do her future wants an um who knows
what's going on behind closed doors you
just never know no I don't think
anyone's perfect you just never know
she could do she could be all those
things and cheap but how can a
traditional woman be a virgin if she's
got family
that's what it doesn't I meant like a
virgin on her wedding night okay
what do you think Auntie wow that's what
I'm thinking maybe she said about
cheating
oh wow no I don't think just because she
could I don't think she should and I
think traditionally they wouldn't
what percent of women do you think want
to be wives and what percent of women do
you think are happy being single
in today's day and age yeah and by by
happy being single means single today
happy for life being single
I think a lot more women are happy being
single nowadays
um
I'd say maybe
40 of women prefer being single 40 I
think so today's day and age and they
would rather be single than with a man
they respect and admire
okay maybe not for like 30. I feel like
a lot more women now would rather I know
a lot of women that value their career
over relationships I know a lot of women
that have not got into relationships
because they're so career driven I think
it happens more in this day and age I'd
say about yeah 30 to 40 percent okay
what do you think
I'll say 20 20 and 80 want to be in
relationships what do you think
um I think if everybody's actually
really honest with themselves I think
100 percent
like you don't who wants to be single
for the rest of their lives that's just
dead if you can find a guy that you can
look here will look you in your eyes and
actually say you know what I love you
and I want you to be my wife I want to
cherish you forever every woman would
lap that up unless she's a lesbian
what do you think are valid reasons for
divorce
um
consistent genuing
consistent cheating domestic abuse all
right so I'm going to make a list
consistent cheating
domestic abuse what else
um drug abuse I think the master
confused
drug abuse
okay what else anything else nice
lies
okay
how many lies just one I just thought
not lies tell me when I'm out of here
okay consistent cheating domestic abuse
drugs drug abuse and lies anything else
he's if he's a psychopath like certain
mental
yeah mental illnesses I think definitely
could could divorce someone or
um poor financial
what's what I'm looking for
like gambling
gambling yeah or like they have they
don't know they can't on addiction an
unhealthy addiction yeah but also one
yeah yeah in an overall
you know that question you asked Pearl
about being happy being single
I think that if you
broke it into age groups it sounds it'd
be different
but if you do like
I say like the 30s and under and the 30s
over or 40s and under you might find
there's more unhappy women
or more women that want to get married
the older they get when they're young
they're happy being single it's only
when they're old and washed up that they
realize that oh I should have had a
man back then it still would have been
with him so I think you might find that
if you'd put an age group on it the
answers would have been different do you
think a lot of women Auntie regret
leaving their husbands in hindsight
I'll say about 75 percent do really yeah
three out of four you would say regret
it why do they regret it later because
they've just done it there was no valid
reason they did it because they could or
because they didn't feel right or they
get bored or he wasn't paying attention
to me off at once there's if it's like
if somebody's life is in danger then
you've got a good reason and if there's
not then you haven't that's my view so
if you're alive for your children's life
or somebody's life is not in danger then
you've got no reason to get divorced
so everything else other than can be
worked on
I mean when you think about it if you
can get divorced for I was thinking
about this the other day if you can get
divorced for pretty much any reason like
not being happy not feeling fulfilled
he's not paying attention to me he's
never home like then why not just be in
a relationship what's the difference
like because if you're married it's
supposed to be for richer for poorer
through thick and then it's like you're
supposed to everything but like I think
that's the way through that yeah I think
the Catholic church is like abuse
addiction like there's or if you know
there's some secret he was hiding that
you didn't know but when you got married
but
otherwise I mean just being a
relationship like why even get married
then
um it depends on what what section
you're talking about I think I'm sure
monogamy is supposed to be a part of
marriage so I feel like if we've decided
to make
um if you decide to get married and tie
ourselves for life
I shouldn't have to accept you
consistently stepping out of the
household
um and have to deal with that throughout
our marriage yeah but I think you should
vet that before you get married yeah but
I feel like this is a nice and unspoken
rule like no one is everyone knows
you're not supposed to cheat in a
relationship or any committed situation
unless you've decided to have an open
relationship you know when I think of
traditional women there's there's a
certain woman that and I've told this
story so many times on the Pod so
they're gonna but it's fine I I think of
there's there's a woman I know she's a
relative she's Catholic okay
she did not believe in divorce she would
rather die like that's when you really
meet someone with a truly traditional
mindset they would rather die than get
divorced like that there's nothing you
could tell her
and her husband
um they lived in Wisconsin and then her
husband like kind of went back and forth
he worked in Chicago he had a side chick
in Chicago like a whole girlfriend in
Chicago okay
and
that that woman she was she was Catholic
and she she like all she prayed to God
she said God please find a way to keep
my family together he left he left the
family all right for the side chick and
she prayed to God please find a solution
help us get back together
and the side chick died
amen
and he came home
and they stayed married and they never
got divorced and when I think of
traditional women that's who I think of
because she would rather die than leave
her man and like how many women have
that mindset of like
she didn't get mad that he cheated she
didn't throw it in his face she didn't
get angry over it and always bring it
back up later she genuinely tried to
find a solution understood where he was
coming from and wanted to keep the
family together no matter what now I'm
not saying you know they had a perfect
marriage or We should strive for that
but I just think like that mentality is
so rare nowadays it's like it's like
they see Instagram and they think
something's going to be better on the
other side and a lot of times it's not
about me sometimes from the where we're
sitting now the culture's here we must
know some old person
that's done that because I know a couple
and I actually know that this this guy
and I always saw him with his wife
and um we just got together and I think
I said oh he's gone somebody said
where's he gone I said oh
so where's your husband assistant
where's your husband that's not my
husband
okay I said someone what's their problem
I actually got everybody said that's not
us that's my husband that's not his wife
so what do you mean they're always
together he's got doggies goes to the
house we've all up into the house you
know he's like another home and then I
met the wife
the wife knew all about it but that was
her husband and if the wife steps in and
if they happen to meet that's something
we're going to a funeral and the wife
was there
she had to step back and hold her place
and because the wife was the wife she
didn't they all had basically Separate
Lives you know the wife's still got the
family home grandkids and everything and
he goes and comes but their wife's got a
they always have to show respect because
she's the wife and there's no way on
Earth that she'd ever give him a divorce
that's her husband her house her
whatever he does outside but he's there
for his grandkids he's there for the
things that husband's supposed to do
but just because something's a tradition
does that mean it should be uphold
forever just because it's a tradition I
believe in death to us part I believe
that if I got married somebody has to
die
I'm a firm believer in that and I that's
my husband if you if I was married and
you want to step out you can step out
and step in as much as like at the end
of the day
I'm I'm not I'm not getting divorced I
mean do you think it's wise to do what's
worked or try something new
um I don't think worked is the right
terminology though I feel I feel like
the word is
um
tolerated I feel like there's a lot of
tolerating going on because something's
a tradition I don't necessarily think
it's worked because but back in back in
the day like my grandparents for example
it was the same concept there was no
such thing as divorce and I know I know
certain couples go through
disrespect and a lot of abuse and a lot
of bad things but you tolerate it
because you don't get divorced I feel
like at some point you have to break
that barrier of okay so you're not
you're not respecting me as an
individual or as the mother of your
children or as your wife but I must deal
with this because we got married
what's better for the children separate
households or one household if if it's a
toxic household and there's abuse going
on separate because children what's
better figuring out how to get along or
continuing to be toxic it takes two to
be toxic 100 but sometimes there isn't
there is no repair sometimes things are
Beyond repair I I think that's a choice
you can't if someone's screaming at you
and argue it's your choice to scream
back 100 but you can also fall out of
love with someone based on repeated
Behavior someone might not adapt or
someone is compromise it has to go is
love a feeling or a choice
loves the feeling
you think so yeah I feel like you can't
so because sometimes you don't want to
love someone but you do if it was a
choice you would decide I don't love you
anymore but it's not always that simple
do you think your your parents always
felt like they loved you
like when like I don't know when I was a
kid there was times I would scream out
of temper tantrums you think my mom in
that moment
just felt love for me
deep deep down yeah but I have a face
value she used to beat me with a spoon
but out of love it was out of love
though yeah but that's what I mean like
she might not have felt like she loved
me but her choices proved that she did
and I think it's the same thing with a
family like I mean in my opinion anyway
I think you know you can feel a certain
way about your husband you might hate
him at some or even what if Michelle
Obama came out and said she hated Barack
for 10 years okay so in a situation
where you've got a husband and a wife
and the husband goes out and he goes to
work and he provides for the family
however he comes home every night and he
beats his wife and then he beats his
kids so should that woman deal with that
and tolerate that for the rest of her
life because she decided to get married
I forget I said what says once nobody's
life's in danger okay
it's really interesting like women
always bring up abuse like we're just
getting beat left and right hmm when the
numbers don't show that the majority of
men are abusing women so that you know
that's not that's an exception it's not
the rule
um yeah I think if your life's in danger
I would agree but I actually would still
um
part of me like I the part of me still
thinks that you should separate not
divorce
so so then was I don't know but I'm not
gonna die on that Hill I haven't thought
that one like don't don't quote me okay
it's like I'm gonna say that for now I
might change my mind later okay
but
it's a paper it's a piece of paper as
well I know isn't it marriage like I
think
now it is I think yeah because
everything that you say in your vows
um you know loving whatever whatever
that's that's someone's actions getting
divorced is it's the paper it's the
legal whatever that word is yeah where a
relationship is something you have to
work on like most people that get
divorced they usually have some form of
relationship sometimes another the love
doesn't die it just evolves somewhere
different like I'm divorced I got
married I was with my um ex-husband for
15 years from 17 onwards and then we got
married in the last year I proposed to
him just because I thought it was the
right thing to do
um and then we we broke up and we don't
really talk we've got a terrible
relationship so you waited 16 years to
get married 15 years 15 years yeah then
you got married
and then you broke up divorced after
yeah yeah because we should have got
married we were trying to do the right
thing for our children
um but you know we just grew apart as
people it wasn't for any real reason I
grew apart couldn't you grow back
together you know because if you grew
one way you could grow the other one
well the thing is Boo like I was 17 when
I got with him I was a child which I
mean that was a 38 year old woman I
don't feel any form of attraction to him
at all the way he talks walks dresses
his whole thing with two completely
different people so you left because you
weren't attracted to him no we left
because we're just two different people
on two different paths because I'm just
thinking I might like my mom met my dad
when she was 17 and I mean there were
times where they didn't like each other
and she probably like you know would
have said the same thing at one at some
points in their marriage but they just
stuck it out and like and now they're
really cute my dad just took her on the
cutest thing because they're getting old
I just wanted to know because I don't
believe that women should ask men yeah I
think that's just a Daniel's world yeah
why did you ask him
um do you think because I find that if a
man's in the Mary is going to be like
yes within the first say three four
years after that it's just because he
feels pressurized by Society we've got
kids or the woman said we've been
together for how many years now you're
gonna make an honest woman of me and
yeah no it's a big mistake personally
like I don't think any woman should
propose to a man I think a man should
take his wife and that's the first
mistake to make
um and also just trying to for me I
wanted him to feel secure in our
relationship because I've always been
quiet not always but I was a little bit
more bigger energy than him and he was a
little he's a Colombian man you know
they think the woman should be and I'm a
British kind of I was right my mom was
single like was raised to be ourselves
really hard and I'm a creative so
there's all these culture caches as well
um but yeah you know I think personally
not everything is about marriage like we
got together when we was children we
don't know ourselves I didn't know
myself as a woman he didn't know himself
as a man so after those three years
we're still what 21 22 we had our first
child we're trying to open up a business
like we weren't a factor of you know um
where it needs to be is something that
kind of felt natural but it wasn't if
you didn't get married would you still
going together no no
the vibe just changed the energy just
changes you want different things from
different people like he's happy to have
a nine to five I don't want that women
always seems to outgrow the men
especially the artists especially the
artists that even book writers musicians
painters or something like that they
move in a different Circle and then all
of a sudden like they're there and and
they see the land is there it's not on
my level anymore or they've outgrown him
or he doesn't understand me I'm mixing
in different circles I've got different
Vibes yeah it wasn't that but I respect
did you feel like that that he was
holding back your career at all yeah a
thousand percent like you know I
remember I had a major audition he said
if you go for that me and you're
breaking up and that's the audition for
big brother and I got three Big
Brother's like you don't know it's a
reality show it's a reality show and
people about 10 people going to a house
and they get watched 24 7 whatever and I
got through quite far and he's like if
you go on it then basically it's either
me or the show obviously is it a dating
show no it's just it's like a social
experiment where they put like 12
different people different personalities
into one house for three months yeah
yeah it's hilarious it's cool
um so yeah and you know he always oh
you're an attention seeker this year
that like he was putting me down from a
young age and not appreciating and
respecting who I was as a person
um but that was his own insecurities
because as much as yeah I'm an artist
and flamboyant and I'm also a loyal
woman I I appreciate and love loyalty
and respect and sacredness and the fact
that I could go out and you know perform
but then come home to my husband would
have been a dream come true for me but
his own ego for whatever reasons
wherever he's come from his environment
he didn't allow it
if he didn't do that would you do you
think it would have worked out 100 yeah
if you would have appreciated me for who
I was as a person so it sounds like he
wanted you to act more traditional in a
way and yeah you were more modern yeah
and then that's what ended the marriage
was he was trying to make you into
something that you're not basically so
I'm not a traditional woman this is what
I've realized this is the conversation
I'm a modern woman so yeah that was the
reason he just realized that
as you know
my husband still to this day if I was a
traditional woman whenever women say
Traditional Values they always say
cooking feeling looking after those and
men can do that easy
whenever they say Traditional Values and
we get to hear something that men agree
on and
let me always say cooking cleaning
looking out for the kids I might just
want someone to have his back and to
enhance him
that's it enhance him grow with him
that's it
but I was glad that you realized that
you weren't traditional because the way
you were saying because
you know when I realized this when you
said oh he said if I was going to go on
Big Brother hmm that it was finished and
I wouldn't but I didn't go on Big
Brother
I missed the opportunity like oh you
listen to him yeah of course I did oh
right yeah if you didn't end up getting
remarried do you think you would regret
it
say it again babe if you didn't end up
getting remarried so if you're if you're
70 60 by yourself would you regret
leaving him yeah because my next part
that I'm with we don't actually
physically have to get married if he
marries himself to me and we're loyal
when we live that way cool but we don't
have to go to a church or go to a
registry office and sign the papers for
the government no but I want to find my
man that's loyal to me I'm loyal to him
that I can give myself to that's what I
want no but I'm saying like if that
didn't happen would you because we were
talking about earlier that a lot of
women regret it because they don't end
up fine I'm not saying that'll happen
I'm just saying if if you were in that
situation do you think you'd regret it
yeah well I'm hoping I don't stay single
for the rest of my life
um yeah because I don't hate the guy I
think if you put in if you put an effort
into anything anything could work out so
I mean I actually I still love the guys
so in a way did you feel like you could
do better than that relationship a
thousand percent but that's only because
I got into a relationship as a child as
a teenager and not as a woman that knows
herself 12 and 17 is an adult I don't
think 17 is an adult not at all 17 is
another all depends on your mindset
exactly I had my son at 17. and I'll be
I had to be an adult so if I was with a
man and get in a relationship you'd have
to be an adult we played the adults yeah
that's what I mean yeah I didn't play
yeah we had the household we had the
children we did we was doing the whole
thing you know what I'm saying but at
the same time I was a child because I'm
emotionally unintelligent so when the
The War of the World actually do start
to come up to you you don't know how to
deal with them properly and that's my
own experience but didn't your mum help
you
um well my mum's come from relationship
after relationship come from a broken
family so I've had to break the
generational curse even I'm not with him
but I'm not out here sleeping with Tom
Dick and Harry I'm celibate like I'm
holding myself down because I don't need
to be doing casual sex and I'm waiting
for my king so in order to wait for my
king I have to hold myself
do you think that men generally want to
wait for women that have had children
already because I've just talked to guys
about this and it's kind of like if you
already have a child no they don't yeah
or they don't like do you think that's a
good strategy no the men don't want
women that have got children
unfortunately because the thought of it
bringing up someone's kid or whatever
but my children they're not children
they're young men no I meant the
celibacy like it sounded like you were
gonna have guys like wait for sex
because you don't own it okay so no
they're not waiting I'm waiting so I'm
not in I'm not in any form of
relationship like I don't even
understand you're focused on the career
yeah and myself though because I don't I
don't like to just let any guy inside of
me because that don't make me feel good
so it's not just about the career
because I'm still I'm single I want a
man I want someone to cause a lot with I
want to have sex I want to have a
connection but I'm not just gonna do it
just because I'd rather hold out I'd
rather be in agony and black I can you
know
not the right guy but you know how how
long ago was the divorce
um it was like
six years ago now do you think it could
ever be reconciled no he just had a baby
oh bless him like he's got a woman and
like no it doesn't I wish that we could
have a good relationship because we're
family we've got children together I
wish we could go out for meals together
and talk and communicate and have a
healthy relationship but I think that's
not gonna happen because he still has
feelings towards me I've got feelings
for him but not in that way so it's it's
awkward so he he has another woman but
he's still he's still a thousand percent
so what does he say he wants to get back
with you we don't talk we don't talk the
last kind of conversation that we had I
he made certain energy clear that there
was still something there and I don't
respect that so if you can't treat me
you know we're not but that's meant for
you so you have to put a boundary how
long ago was that um that's about
two years ago so you haven't spoken in
two years no do you think maybe he
doesn't have the same feelings now that
he's just had the kid I would love that
if that was the case but then we would
be able to have a healthy relationship
isn't it if there was no feelings there
so it's just how it is the kids don't
you guys have to communicate to her
um well my children are grown now and
when we when we divorced how old's your
youngest 15. okay but he doesn't go to
his dad's yeah he goes to his dad's they
see each other they've got a healthy
relationship my children have got but
relationships with both of us and we
communicate very clearly with them so
like I said because I'm a young mom
um and I've experienced coming from a
broken home I made sure my children
didn't go through that so I always speak
to my children communicate look me and
his dad not together but you know we
still care about you you can have two
different lives two different homes they
stay there stay at my house it's it's
healthy it's unfortunate but it is what
it is Young mum yeah is it hard ever
like around the holidays like having I'm
assuming you go switch I'm
so basically every other so this next
year I'm gonna have them Christmas he
has some New Year's vice versa we just
do it that way is is that hard or is
that okay no it's lovely because that
means that we both get to do our own
thing every other time and I think it's
great
one question popped up in my head at
what age do you expect to stop having
sex
all of you never until my body's broken
okay
that's an interesting question
I mean I don't think I can put an H on
it okay just until your buddies
basically just can't physically do it
anymore
yeah I agree no there isn't a number I
just wondered because some people have
numbers and I think well have you got a
number yeah so I just want to see if
anybody only had an actual number
because as far as I'm concerned there is
no number how long do you think women
should wait before having sex with a new
guy
for me it's about commitment so until we
are committed to each other and that's
no matter how long that takes until he's
in a relationship with you yeah but
where I'm at right now most likely until
we're married
okay so you want to be celibate until
you're married yeah so where am I where
I am in my life right now yes do you do
you think that's fair to ask of a guy if
the last guy didn't have to do that
um not necessarily that's not fair no
ways only it's not unfair it's not
unfair to him I like that
um I'm just I'm just going to give you
I'm gonna do this blessing do you think
that's unfair
hell yeah
I think How would how would that go over
for you if a girl asks you to wait when
she does she's not a virgin I'm good
listen think about listen
listen I know what she's gonna say
that was before she was a Christian
she's a Christian and she's in church
would you wait if he was a church man no
if he was a church man no I mean
committed he knows what I mean what
okay
[Laughter]
um how long do you wait do you think do
you think girls should wait good you
could say how long you think girls
should wait it's gonna be a
controversial opinion but
I think it depends on the situation
because you could be in a situation
where you hold out then I think girls
hold out because it's off the basis they
think men respect them more if they hold
out but you can hold out have sex with
someone and then they're like they're on
to the next you don't think it matters
how long you wait
um I don't think not in the first not on
the first date I don't think you should
it it happens but I feel like at least
the first date you can kind of hold it
out
um
baby like third date I would say roughly
third date yeah how long would you have
known him from the first to the third
date like how long does that take
usually
um before I go on a date I need to speak
to them for a bit so you're talking
maybe like two three week speaking
period there may be a date a week so so
like three three weeks roughly a month
that's a lot of money I would date a
week no like on by the third date I mean
so you go first date one week then
second date the week after then the
third date the week after that who's
playing for these days
um it depends I think if he says to me I
want to take you for dinner that first
day he should be paying then after that
it's like 50 50.
um yeah okay
what do you think how long
like it's all about energy because the
body is the body and Science and
hormones and chemistry and
stuff like that so I think it's when you
feel comfortable with that person for me
I know that I want to be exclusive and
it needs to be a commitment I'm not
going to be having sex with somebody
that's having sex with other women
um so yeah I think I just need to go
with my instincts to be honest but it
definitely won't be on the first date
or the second date like it
Fifth Third
um I'll be honest I don't date like I
haven't even ever done that I've always
known somebody and then moving Oh you
mean they're like friends yeah like or
you know them in some form of way like I
won't just meet us like somebody so you
meet you know I'd say
and my my producer has a girlfriend but
let's just pretend there's another one
there he's single you just me and you're
friends right yeah you know so then how
long
uh you know he's not a serial killer he
knows a couple people you know yeah it
needs a time and he's a few weeks okay a
few weeks yeah okay okay Auntie how long
I know it's been a while since you've
been in the dating game but
I think nowadays it's like
as soon as
you want nowadays because I find out
that dates will involve sex in my day
I've been up I've been seeing guys for
like a year and never had six of them we
just got friends together go out
together in groups and single
and then you think nah they wanna well
then you might think yeah then
afterwards you think now but
I think as long as it takes but if I
knew them what I knew now
lock it down from the beginning
I just wait till I'm a virgin and
because I was really unattractive I'll
be the oldest virgin girl auntie auntie
if they're not virgins how long if
they're not virgins yeah
that's what these dating sites are in it
you'll you'll like linking people oh no
I'm not talking like that I'm talking
about like meeting somebody for I don't
believe in dating sites I'm talking
about you meet someone you can psych
them out you you know where they're
coming from because you never just go
and pick up someone and go on a date
you're gonna know them from before so
nowadays if you're single you've got no
kids and you want to free it up free up
you want to be slight go ahead free up
if not just don't blessing guys point of
view how long should women wait
how many hours
how many how many days how many dates
roughly dates yeah date
for this one
okay if he was my sister she can wait a
long time
but I ain't know these girls they have
to give it up
right now yeah the mentality is if
you're not doing it someone else is
doing it if you're not doing that
somebody else is
for your sister how long can she wait
does she have to wait so she's married
yes yeah she went forever
[Music]
any more questions
at what age did you use your virginity
16.
no comment
yeah I'm gonna say no comment as well
I use I was young though I wouldn't want
my daughter to lose her virginity that
young and I was extremely promiscuous as
well at a very young age
um but obviously I I believe in
different things I believe in certain
influences
whether that be your environment
spiritual whatever but what I know is
that I'm learning from my mistakes and
if I had a daughter
um I would teach her certain things I
feel I feel like I personally was left
to just grow instead of having a woman
and a I didn't have my dad or my mom
there to guide me I was observing my mom
having you know I'm not gonna expose
something I grew up around people right
with mums and dads yeah and it's only
when I was an adult I realized that all
my friends I was playing with were
actually out there having sex and I was
like but we were at school that was like
yeah we were happy and I just I just
couldn't believe it but it was out then
there's people out there having sex
well I know is that my son he's 17 now
but he broke his virginity when he was
16 which I'm happy about I wish he would
have left it longer but or whatever and
then my 15 year old he's still a virgin
so we're good for now
I'm gonna look at my grandchildren my
grandchildren having no sex until I say
oh my gosh I found out
on sneako streamed my sister had had sex
I was like
I was like gas
like no my little sister because someone
said like what's her body count in the
comments and I I was like don't answer
that and then and then I was thinking
she was a virgin then sneaker she got
away and they had a way of going around
the question and then she was like one
and I was like
no
and she's quite old compared to the
girls nowadays yeah I know she is older
like but yeah I was like
um okay you got any more Auntie how many
kids use of funny gonna have
I don't know if you've got any I know
she is but how many do you want and by
what age do you want to have all of them
um I want to have four
and latest maybe like 38 39
I want to have three and latest
28 29.
I would like to have one more little
girl
um star but I need to have certain
things in place
and that I was gonna say how do you know
you're gonna have a girl but then you're
gonna tell me Oh I thought he's gonna
tell me that you're going to connect the
stars and make sure it is
and then you know until my body's the
right temperature to his and then we're
gonna produce this girl that's what I
was waiting for right age would you guys
like to start having kids and would you
have to be married to have a child
say I would have to be married 100
um
because I was raised by a single mother
and I saw how hard it was for her so I
don't want that for myself
um but definitely like 26 27 okay but at
the same time it just depends on my
circumstances as well
um but I'll definitely have to be
married yeah what about you
um I'd prefer to be married it's not
really a door breaker for me
um but
I don't I don't think I'm ready to have
my first child at least until I'm about
29 30 29 30. yeah okay what about you
um both my children were planned so I
had my first child when I was 20. and
then the next one I was 22 because I
wanted to be a young mom and grow with
them and be youthful and stuff but I
just I don't know it's all about your
maturity I suppose and I think that your
your financial situation definitely
needs to be fought about as well
okay so what age would you want to have
your next oh the next one okay so I'm 39
like if I'm gonna have another child it
needs to be in the next like five years
if I haven't got another child in next
five years but I'm not gonna say oh I
can't have any more children because if
I'm having sex with my man unprotectedly
my my guy and and we have a baby that's
God's will that what am I supposed to
so yeah you just kind of shoot up see
what happens
you know once I've got those Millions
yeah
I need a woman she had a baby and she
was in the early 50s 60s and she had it
naturally yeah totally unexpected
they're having a baby's not a problem is
but it's like what happens the next
decade you're going to be 60 you're
doing school around there's that's what
I think about as well
you know it's not just about if your
body can carry it because having to say
that when you go into if you take your
church at the age if you take your child
into the school and you're going to be
looked at as a grandparent or the great
grandparent well this is your granny no
that's my mom yeah and people need to
think about having children like because
I knew a woman and she had a child late
and it's only and her daughter got
married and left that a daughter told
her how scared she was all of her life
that her mom was gonna die exactly
because my mother and she really thought
yeah growing up and their mum didn't
know that it's not nice
[Music]
do you have any warranty how many you
good enough bro what how many kids
you're gonna have come on I want to be
good mother
um
no I mean I think maybe if I started
younger yeah like I could have had more
but now I probably want four kids I
think okay I think four is I really
liked when my family was around four I
thought six it gets kind of hectic but
like four or five is like nice
[Music]
um
yeah six was a lot that was a lot in the
house at the same time there's always
someone screaming but it was really fun
too so that's why he's being part of a
big family I hated it really I always
wanted to be a nouny child I loved it
they were too noisy too boisterous too
I hated it yeah but see it's
interesting because we have different
experiences
now even growing up I was just the weird
one I just like quiet libraries books
and they like music boys you know
dancing TV and movies and the hate
watching movies and stuff like that so I
never fitted in I just tell people that
they handed the wrong child at the
hospital that was my excuse why are you
like them oh I'm just different I think
they handed the wrong child at the
hospital would you guys ever adopt
yeah yeah
I haven't really thought of it but
maybe maybe I would adopt inside the
family not out I fostered
and now I think I'd adopt inside the
family
I I wouldn't adopt outside the family
I
think it comes with a lot of issues that
people don't really think about so I
don't
and because I've got no other children
around but I find it I've fostered when
my son was young and he always had
children around and it's you it's a
balance
you know you've got to balance it with
your children that child and how your
child feels so I think adoption is just
if it's a family member or a close
friend and they die they're from a good
parent to someone and they die fine but
either that or if I get if I meet a
younger man and I can't have a child if
I get a younger man now if I wanted to
choose but no definitely adopt family I
wouldn't mind adopting I actually had a
dream that I adopted this little girl
the other day she's three months no
she's three months old but she had a big
like Bob and she could speak fluent like
literally but I think some people they
need you know we need to adopt each
other in a certain way and especially if
you've got the the means to do it and
the love why not like it's all about
relationship that's the most important
thing communication and relationship as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible